just let me know when to start. Yes, we can start.
Hello everyone, welcome to the second session of today's lectures. I am, my name is Avigyan.
I am a faculty member in the department of computer science and engineering at IIT Kharagpur
and today I am going to talk about supervised machine learning. You have already heard from
professor Shudhishthir Sarkar about logistic and linear regressions. I will continue talking
about other supervised machine learning models, for example, base classifier, KNN and support
vector machine or SVM. So, just a quick recap, classification is a problem which is defined
with respect to a tuple x and y, where x is a set of attributes or feature or it are also
called like independent variables associated with some input and y are the class or labels
or the dependent variable associated with the output. Once we have a record of a lot
of such x and y's, the task is to learn a model that can map each attribute set x into
one of the predefined classables y, so that when a new test data point comes, the model
can look at the x for the test set and can predict the y for the same test set.
So, for example, one example classification task is categorizing email messages as spam
or non-spam. So, in this case the attribute set or x will be the features which are extracted
from the email message either the header or the body of the email and the class label
will be spam or non-spam. And in this case, since we are talking about only two classes
in the prediction or in the class label, so this is called a binary classification task.
On the other hand, let us take another example like identifying tumor cells to be malignant
or benign, in this case the features can be the x-ray image or MRI scan and it can contain
a lot of features like that or you can even take the pixel values which are there in the
image they all form the attribute set x. This is the general approach of building any classifier,
so you have a training set. The training set is used to learn a model using some learning
algorithm and this step is called an induction step. Once the model is learned, then for
a given test input in the real application scenario, you apply the model and try to predict
what is going to be the label of that particular particular input which has come and this step
is called deduction. So, in case of induction, we use the training data set to learn a model
and in case of deduction, we use the same model to predict output for a test input.
So in this lecture, we are going to talk about several classification techniques, notably
we will talk about knife base nearest neighbor and support vector machines. You have already
heard about logistic and linear regression. So, I have removed them from this list. Logistic
regression is a classification model which I am not going to cover, but in the next
lecture next week, I am also going to cover decision tree and the boosting, bagging and
random forest methods. The only thing which we will not cover which will be covered in
some little lectures is on neural networks. So, let us just start our discussion on knife
base. Before that, let us take an example application. Let us just assume that we have
been asked to recognize digits from a lot of handwritten digits. So, now in like where
this kind of problem can occur, let us say a particular bank is trying to automate the
check processing service. So, if you want to automate that, then the
check is placed on a particular machine, it is scanned and from that scanned check leaf,
you will have to deduct the amount which has been asked to be deducted from the account
of the payee. Now in this case, the numbers that means the amount which needs to be deducted
from the payee's account, that will be written like an handwritten digit. Let us say someone
wants to give a 50,000 rupees check, the amount part will have something like this.
Now the job of the algorithm to figure out what exactly the person has written. Is this
a 5 or a 6? Is this a 0 or 1? Is this again like another 0 or 1 or maybe 6 or something
like that? So, this is called a handwritten digit recognition problem. So, we are looking
at the handwritten digits, we want to actually map them to a particular number. In this example,
let us say that we are looking at an scanned image of handwritten digit, here we can clearly
understand this is a 5, but for a computer to understand this, basically the input is
a set of pixel values. So, essentially here it is a 30 cross 30 box. So, there are 900
pixel values there, essentially every pixel value you can take as a feature. So, there
are like 900 features, each feature is just either 0 or 1. So, here let us say I present
all the pixel values as x 1 to x n and every x 1 to x n is either 0 or 1, in this picture
it is either a blue pixel or a red pixel and then we want to predict a level y.
Now, in this case just for simplicity, we are thinking of the prediction to be only
either 5 or 6, just to think of this as a binary classification problem, but in reality
you would like to have a 9 class or 10 class classification starting from 0 all the way
to 9. So, given a particular input image, you will have to recognize whether the digit
inside that image is whether 0, 1, 2, 3 all the way up to 9, one of them. Now, for this
example let us just focus or restrict ourselves to only a binary prediction 5 or 6.
Now, so once we understand this, so if you look at this, so every pixel value is essentially
this x 1, x 2 all the way up to x n. So, what we are interested in is knowing the probability
of a given level, probability of a level given all the pixel values. So, if we think of them
as the pixel values in the image, this is either 5 or 6. So, we are going to determine
the probability of 5 given all the pixel value, probability of 6 given all the pixel value
and take the one which leads to the highest probability. So, that is why this arg max
is applied and that y is going to be our prediction. So, if the probability of 5 given all the
pixel value is more than the probability of 6 given the pixel value, then the prediction
will be 5. Now, the question is how do we compute this
probability? Now, in general if you think of this, given all the pixel values whether
it is a 5 or 6 that is our fundamental question. So, we cannot directly compute this. So, we
will have to compute this through some other mechanism and this is where Bayes rule or
Bayes theorem comes into picture. So, Bayes rule says that probability of y given x 1
all the way up to x n is equal to probability of x 1 all the way up to x n given y into
probability of y divided by probability of x 1 all the way up to x n. Now, this particular
term is called likelihood, this particular term is called prior.
Now, what is this? So, if you think about it essentially what this probability is saying
probability of x 1 all the way up to x n given y that when you are writing let us say 5 and
this let us say my box. So, which of the pixel values are getting turned on? So, essentially
if you think about this if this is my 5. So, all the pixel values where I am just writing
over. So, they will become red if you think like red to be 1 and white to be 0. So, then
only this pixel values will have 1 and all others will have 0.
Now, computing this is much easier because you are already knowing that y value is 5
like there is no kind of there is no suspense regarding y we are knowingly writing 5. So,
so that way if you collect a lot of 5 written by like different people. So, some people
may write 5 like this some people may write 5 like this some people may write 5 like this.
So, there are a lot of variations of 5 which people can write if you can collect a lot
of data like that you will know which of the pixel values are typically turned on when
someone writes 5 in any of the styles. So, this is why we say that this likelihood function
actually captures how features are generated by the class level. So, here the class level
is 5 or 6. So, the likelihood function is going to capture which of the input features
or the input pixel values are 1 which of them are 0 as if being generated by the class level
5 or 6 and the prior at the same time is also simple.
So, probability of y. So, if you have a lot of checks like going back to our this check
example if you have a lot of check books or check leaves you know how many times people
write like 50000 how many times people write 60000. So, essentially how many times the letter
or the digit 5 is written how many times the letter the digit 6 is written this we can
capture if we have sufficient number of check leaves. So, that gives us the probability
of y. So, essentially by looking at a lot of examples we can we can identify probability
of x 1 all the way up to x n given y some at the same time the probability of y can
also be figured out if we have enough training data. So, that way we can compute this I will
talk for now we can treat the denominator to be a normalization constant we will see
that this constant actually do not matter when we are trying to compute the level the
out the final outcome. So, see that when we are in our digit recognition
task that we are trying to capture probability of y is equal to 5 given all the pixel values
probability of y is equal to 6 given all the 6 pixel values this is what we are getting
probability of x 1 till x n given y is equal to 5 probability of x 1 till x n given y is
equal to 6 and if you look at carefully the denominator in both cases are the same constant.
So, when you are comparing between probability of y is equal to 5 and probability of y is
equal to 6 and trying to determine which one is larger than the other you can simply discard
the denominator because they are the same. So, that does not impact your calculation.
So, to classify we are just going to compute these two probabilities the likelihood and
the prior and based on which one is greater we are going to predict the class length.
Now, so we understand that for the base classifier we just need to learn two functions the likelihood
function and the prior function. Now, the problem with explicitly modeling this is that
so, we are basically looking at all the pixel values together and then determining what
are going to be the values like whether 1 or 0 given a particular value of y.
Now, typically so, this kind of tells us that we have to keep track of a whole lot combination
of values like 0, 1, 1, 0, 1 and every value is dependent on each other. Now, that will
lead to very high space and time complexity and typically to learn this we will need a
lot of training data which we ideally do not have. Now, to simplify this in the knife based
classification model there is a knife based assumption and this assumption is that given
a particular class level the features or in this case let us say the pixel values they
are independent of each other. So, for example, again going back to our example of digit and
the corresponding pixel. So, let us say when I write 6 the what the knife based assumption
says is that if you take a particular pixel value here whether it is turned on and or
off does not depend on the adjacent pixel value. So, it does not depend on any other
pixel value in the image. So, whether it is turned on and on or off that solely depends
on only the digit what is being written here alright understood.
So, if I am writing 6 like this all this pixels are getting turned on, but they are independent
of pixels other pixels in the image. So, they are only dependent on the digit which is being
written here. So, that is the knife based assumption. So, if you if we write it in mathematical
expression essentially the probability of x 1 to x n given y is just a product of probability
individual probabilities of x i given y. So, if there are let us say 10 pixels here it
is just going to be a multiplication of 10 different probabilities that means the values
of 10 different pixels in that image. Now, why is this useful as I mentioned that
in in case we wanted to get all the pixel combinations. So, this actually leads to a
lot of combinatorial explosion and the number of parameters we will have to learn for that
model is 2 times 2 to the power n minus 1 which is a huge number. On the other hand
if we have the independence assumption in that case the number of parameters which are
there for modeling the individual probabilities is way lesser and in fact it boils down to
2 times n where n is the number of pixels. Now, as I was mentioning earlier that when
we have decided to use a knife based classifier we need to train it with some data. Now, in
this case now you can take a lot of check lips for example and see how different customers
in a bank have written 5 or 6. So, if you know that this was indeed 50000 rupees you
can figure out like these are different ways people have written 5 or 0.
Similarly, if you know that the actual money which was transacted was like 60000 or 660000
you can look at that check lip and then look at like how people have written 6 and and
see more data you collect you actually get to know more variations. So, this is a let
us say standard 6, but if you look at this this is really something which otherwise it
will not appear to be a 6 these are this. So, the only way to know this different variations
is to gather as much data as possible. So, that you do not miss any like new customer
who may have a different writing style than all other people.
So, again this is something as I was mentioning earlier that once you have a collection of
records the training data it is in general training is very easy. So, you kind of estimate
the fraction of records with y the value of y to be v and the probability of y is equal
to v is essentially just the count of records. So, you know how many records are there you
know out of them how many records have y of a particular value v. Now, in this case let
us say you have 100 check leaves and out of all the 100 check leaves in 50 check leaves
you have the digit 5 and in 50 check leaves you have the digit 6 in that case the probability
of y is equal to 5 or probability of y is equal to 6 will be 50 percent or 0.5.
Similarly, to note the probability of a particular pixel value to be let us say u in this case
like just 0 or 1 given a probability given a particular y value is again you can just
simply count. So, you can count in how many of your examples when I have written 5 like
I means like some customer has written 5 in how many cases this particular pixel value
was 1 and in how many cases let us say this particular pixel value was 0. So, you can
simply compute that that will give you this a probability of x i is equal to u now in
this case u is just 0 or 1 and v in this case is 5 or 6 in our example.
So, this is how we compute this and in general knife base training is quite easy. The only
issue is that in many cases some of this counts may be 0. So, for example, here you are looking
at the count of records count is equal to count y is equal to v it may so happen that
let us say you are trying to have a class level which is not present in the dataset which
you have given. For example, if you have collected a dataset full of like 50000 rupees check leaves
in that case like there is no mention of digit 6 in that case the count will simply be 0.
Now, the problem is just not about count being 0 because then your probability is just 0,
but the problem is that to compute the individual conditional probabilities the count comes
in the denominator. So, if this is 0 then you will get an error because you are trying
to divide by 0. Now, to overcome this instead of just having
the probability to just be a fraction of counts we tend to add some extra values like in this
case we add plus 1 in the numerator and we add 2 in the denominator. So, this particular
technique is called smoothing technique so that the values does not become 0 and does
not cause any problem in the calculation. So, typically like we collect so many different
pixels sorry we collect so many different examples as training data and then we actually
average all the trainings of one digit versus another digit and then in the test time you
try to figure out a given a particular pixel value like whether this is going to be 6 or
this is going to be 5. Now, one example is let us say when you provide
this particular image to the naive based model it predicts 5 with a very high probability
of 1. So, the probability of 6 in this case is just like 0. When given this image you
get a probability of 6 sorry we you get a prediction of 6 again with a very high probability,
but one problem with this kind of classification model is that since it has been trained on
just like 5 or 6. So, given a new data point even if that data point does not belong to
any of these classes it will kind of force it to take except one class. So, in this case
it has predicted it to be 5 although clearly this is not a 5.
Now, how can we mitigate this problem? The problem can be easily mitigated if instead
of learning a binary classifier like where we are just trying to differentiate between
digit 5 and digit 6. If we learnt a multiclass 10 class classifier between 0 to 9 then in
that case we would have seen enough example of 2 and in that case we could have predicted
this properly because we are anyway training for that. So, so often time the binary classification
is just not sufficient and depending on the problem you will have to pick multiclass classification
and not restrict with binary classification, but the same knife based classification technique
can work because it is again talking about just the probability it does not matter whether
you are having just like 2 classes, 2 output classes or 10 output class. You are going
to check which probability is higher and then only going to assign that particular output
to that particular input data for whom you got the maximum probability.
Let us look at another example. So, this is an example about given a weather condition
whether a match is going to be played or not. You can imagine this to be let us say a cricket
match. So, you know so essentially let us say you know when the outlook was sunny based
on your training data, 2 times match was played and 3 times match was not played. Similarly,
when there is the outlook is overcast, 4 times the match was played and none of the times
the match was not played and you get all this data point based on the observations.
Now, a new day comes and the new day has certain values like the outlook is sunny, the temperature
is cold, humidity is high, there is wind in the ground and you will have to determine
whether there any match will get played or not. So, to do that what we will have to do
sorry there was a little mistake here. So, essentially here outlook is sunny and we are
looking at whether the on a particular I mean how many days the outlook was sunny and how
many days the outlook was not sunny. Similarly, how many days the outlook was overcast, how
many days the outlook was not overcast, how many days the outlook was rainy, how many
days the outlook was not rainy and correspondingly we know how many days there was a match played
and how many days the match was not played. Now, based on this we can compute the probability
that if it is sunny then in that case the probability of match getting played is 2 by 9, while when
the outlook is not sunny in that case there is 3 by 5 probability of there being no match.
So, you compute all this information and then you apply it in the actual test example. Now,
in this case this was the test example. The likelihood of a match being played is so when
outlook is sunny you look at 2 by 9. So, this 2 by 9 corresponds to that when the outlook
when the temperature is cool. So, temperature cool is this. So, this is 3 by 9. So, you
get 3 by 9. Similarly, humidity is high humidity high you get 3 by 9 again. So, you get 3 by
9 and you can do all the way up to this you get a value of 0.0053. Similarly, the likelihood
of there being no match is just 3 by 5. Here if you look at this was 3 by 5 because outlook
is sunny 1 by 5 temperature cool you look at cool 1 by 5 4 by 5 4 by 5 comes from here
the humidity was high and so on and the value is 0.206. Now, since 0.0053 is lower than 0.0206
our prediction is that given the current weather condition there is going to be no match.
Now, in knife base we actually made this knife base assumption where we said that all features
are independent given the class level Y. Now, the question is that does it hold for the digit
recognition problem. So, in digit recognition you see that when I am writing this 5 it is
often there is a correlation that if a particular. So, if a particular digit is actually turned
on there is a very high probability that the digits adjacent to that will also be turned
on. Now, you cannot write 5 for example, like this right like let us say one thing is turned
on one thing is not turned on this will not become like a 5, but when you actually connect
all these dots and then only it becomes a 5 right. So, there is a very high correlation
between what a particular pixel value a particular pixel will take and the correlation is with
its neighbors like it depends on the neighbors around it. If a particular value is 1 a pixel
value there is a very high likelihood that the neighbor will also have a pixel value
1. Similarly, if the pixel value is 0 then there will be a very high probability that
the neighboring pixel value will also be 0. So, the bottom line is that this independence
assumption does not actually hold for a digit recognition problem and not only in this case
in many other scenario for example, if our the class level let us say it follows a ZOR
function. In this case you see that the output depends on both x 1 and x 2 you cannot you
cannot just separate them out just you cannot treat them independently because otherwise
like that is the property of this ZOR function right like when both are 0 the value becomes
1 when both are 1 the value becomes 1 and all of the scenario the value is not going
to be 1 right. So, sorry when both are 0 the value is going to be 0. So, probability of
y 0 this becomes 1. Similarly, when both are 0 the value is 1. So, the value is 0. So,
probability of y is equal to 1 given x 1 x 2 will be 0. Now, this clearly is dependent
on both x 1 and x 2 value and you cannot determine this independent of each other.
So, the bottom line is that the knife base assumption is almost never true, but still
we use them because knife base often perform significantly well even when its assumption
do not hold. And as you see in machine learning a lot of things although like there are theories
behind all the models how the models have been developed there is a mathematical foundation,
but the end of the day it is also very application driven field.
So, if in reality you see that some particular model or some approach is working very well
even if like there is no solid theoretical backing of why it is working so well we still
tend to take that because it is working very well. So, we do not care often about like
whether there it is theoretical sound or not. So, the same thing holds for knife base knife
base often works very well in practice and this is why it is often classification algorithm
of choice for a lot of application. Now, one thing in case of knife base is that
often time we may have to deal with multiplying a lot of small probabilities because you see
that here after the independence assumption what we did was so essentially probability
of x 1 all the way up to x n given y this was a multiplication of individual probability
values individual conditional probability value. Now, what happens that often time these probabilities
are very small and if you are multiplying over a lot of pixels. So, let us say your
image has 2000 pixels. So, in that case if you just input it in any software it will
be very close to 0. So, in this case like even if you think of a value to be like 0.5
a particular probability value if you multiply it by 2000 times; that means, like 0.5 to
2 to the power 2000 it will be like 0 because this will be very small number which I mean
in general the computational software will just treat to be 0. So, this actually this
is also known as a floating point under flow that when you are multiplying lots of probabilities
then it can lead to a floating point under flow and to counter that often time we use
logarithm. So, instead of multiplying two values let
us say x and y if we take a log of that and then it becomes log of x plus log of y. So,
it is better to sum logs of probabilities than multiplying the individual probabilities
because then just sum does not lead to floating point under flow.
So, essentially the night base it becomes like this that instead of earlier we were looking
at the multiplication of the likelihood and the prior function. In this case we are just
taking the logarithm of the prior and then summing it up with the logarithm of the likelihood
and then whichever is giving us the highest value we are just going to take that. So,
that arg max stays, but internally the multiplication of probabilities actually gets replaced by
a sum of logarithm. So, instead of just comparing directly the probabilities we compare the
logarithm of the probabilities. So, to summarize we defined the base classifier, but saw that
it is kind of intractable to compute a probability of x 1 till x n given y. So, we actually use
the night base assumption that everything is independent given the class level y and
to counter or avoid the floating point under flow we used logarithms.
Now, in general night base is very easy to implement and often it works very well and
it is often a very good first attempt or first classification attempt to try and then depending
on the result either you take it if the performance is above a certain threshold if not then you
tend to look for some other algorithms. Now, let us also look at some other algorithm
beyond night base and this algorithm is called nearest neighbor classifier or often time you
may have heard this abbreviation called KNN. K stands for the number of neighbors you are
considering. So, KNN is called KN nearest neighbor algorithm.
So, this is an example of something called an instance base classifier. So, what is an
instance base classifier? So, essentially in your training data if you go back to our
example of this check leaves. So, let us say a bank is collecting all the check leaves
which are deposited in its system and then depending on the bank clerk or by the bank
officer whoever has released the amount it can know that this check leaf this particular
digits which were written there it correspond to this actual number.
Now this you can think of this like the set of all stored data. In this case let us say
the attributes you can think of the pixel values and the class is like 5, 6, 7, 8 like
the way we have written. Now some new check leaf comes, some new customer has written
an amount and we will have to determine what is this amount. So, one option is that you
actually look at the training record and training record is going to tell you what is the level
of the unseen the new test example. So, one very crude or naive algorithm would
be a Rotlerner which memorizes the entire training data and if a particular handwritten
like a particular check leaf for example is very similar to one other check leaf which
is there in the system or it may so happen that the same customer has come again who
has deposited another check leaf let us say one month prior. So, you can just match this
and can figure out that the person is again trying to withdraw let us say 5000 rupees.
So that will be a learner which is called a Rotlerner because it memorizes the entire
training data and performs classification only if the attributes of the record in this
case the pixel values of the record match one of the training data points completely.
Now nearest neighbor approach actually takes one step beyond this. So, it says that it
is impractical to assume that whenever I am looking at a check leaf though exactly same
check leaf is present in the system may be from a different record earlier. Now it can
happen but there is no guarantee that it will happen. So, instead of relying on that let
us actually look at the k closest points. So, given a new check leaf rather than finding
the exact match for this check leaf in our system let us try to take 5 closest check
leaves which were deposited in the system earlier and based on that we are going to
predict what is going to be the value of the new check leaf or what is the amount which
is written on the new check leaf. So, like in a funny way the basic idea of
nearest neighbor classifier is that if a particular text example works like a duck looks like
a duck coax like a duck then it is probably a duck. Now in reality it may not be a duck
for example here like you see this can simply be a toy mimicking a duck, but these are the
examples where they are like actual ducks. But anyway I mean since it looks like a duck
we will call it a duck. So, this is the whole idea of k nearest neighbor that we try to look
at the k nearest records and then depending on the k nearest records we are going to predict
the level of the test example. Here is one other example that let us say
these are all the stored records and these are the labels which are there in the stored
record. Now a new example comes I look at which other examples are similar to this example
now in this case let us say I am looking at a neighborhood of this and in this neighborhood
all other examples are plus. So, in that case we simply assign the class level plus to this
unknown record. Now for this two work you require three things first we need the set
of stored records then we talked about this nearest examples. So, to compute which point
is nearest to which other point we will have to have a distance metric and based on the
distance metric we are going to compute the neighbors.
And then we also need the value of k that is the number of nearest neighbors we need
to retrieve the value of a particular test example. Now when an unknown record comes
as soon as we compute as soon as an unknown record comes we compute the distance to other
training records we identify which are the k nearest neighbors and then we use the class
levels of the nearest neighbors to determine the class level of the unknown record. So,
depending on the value of k the neighborhood size kind of changes. So, for example in the
leftmost picture you see this is called the one nearest neighbor because here we are just
determining or trying to identify the closest data point to the unseen record.
And essentially here we are just going to look at one neighbor and look at the predicted
or look at the output of that one neighbor and then I predict the output of the new record
to be the same as the nearest neighbor which I have identified. Similarly, when we look
at the two nearest neighbor there are two values and we will have to pick one of the
values. Similarly, for three nearest neighbor, four nearest neighbor, five nearest neighbor
with increasing k two things are happening our neighborhood size is increasing and at
the same time we also need to deal with scenarios where all the neighbors may not have the same
level. So, often time we pick one the value of k such that it is an odd value. So, that
if you take a vote let us say you look at all the levels of its neighbors you pick the
one which has got the maximum level. So, since the number of neighbors you are considering
odd is odd. So, essentially we will have one winner. Now, here are several examples of
neighbor classification algorithm like the distance which are used to compute the neighbors.
One is Euclidean distance another is Manhattan distance and there is a generalized form
called q non distance and they all follow the same approach. So, let us say this is
a two dimensional space and what does two dimensional space means that you are essentially
dealing with two features like your data point actually has two features. So, let us say
features x 1 feature x 2 and this data point let us say you call as p and this data point
you call as q. So, essentially if you have just like two features your i is equal to
1 to 2 in this case is x 1 and x 2. So, you look at the value of p for axis x 2 the value
of q over the axis x 2 take the difference make a square of it and then sum it with the
difference between the value of p on x 2 x 1 the value of q on x 1 take the difference
and then you square it and just add it up. In case of Manhattan distance instead of taking
the square and adding it up you just add up the absolute difference.
Again in case of q non you go beyond 2 and you can even take let us say a cubic distance
and then equivalently you will have to take 1 by q th root of or q th root of that particular
sum. And as I mentioned the determining the class level from the nearest neighbor list
is often very easy that if you select k a to be an odd number that essentially you can
take the majority vote and pick the class level which is present in the majority of
instances. Now you can have a little bit more complicated voting method where you can think
of this as an weighted voting that instead of so let us say if my test data point is
this and my neighborhood consist of let us say crosses and ticks.
So, in a in case of majority voting in this case you simply see that my neighborhood let
us just take k is equal to 5 let us say here there is another sorry so this is a cross.
So, let us say there is another cross here, but if you are looking at a simple majority
vote then you have 3 ticks and 2 crosses. So, in that case you will predict the output
to be output will be a tick right for this new data point. However, if you actually look
at the distance maybe this crosses are closer to it than the ticks. So, in case of weighted
voting you actually weigh the vote according to the distance. So, essentially your weighing
factor is 1 by distance square. So, if a particular point is much it is further away from the
test data then the corresponding class level has a lower impact compared to another data
point where it is much closer to the test data point. So, this is essentially the KNN
classification algorithm. If you know the K that is the number of nearest neighbors we
are considering and let us take D to be the set of training example for every test example
Z. We are going to compute the distance between the feature set X prime for the test example,
the feature set X for the training example and likewise you compute this for every pair
of point. So, essentially for every new test data point you compute the distance with all
the existing training data point and then you select the K closest neighbor once you
select that if your selection is based on a majority voting you just look at like which
particular output level is more prominent or more frequent in the neighborhood set and
you just simply assign that output to the to the I mean you just simply take that level
to be your output level. Again, here there is a real world example this
is for like loan. So, see that there are multiple data points let us say and here we are plotting
age as the X axis and the loan amount as the Y axis and as you see that with increasing
age and increasing loan amount there are a lot of default. So, and there are non-default
when the age is lower or the loan amount is lower. Now, a new data point comes so we actually
look at the neighbors the nearest neighbors and see what kind of labels they have. Now,
in this case if your algorithm is just majority voting it will lead to a deadlock because here
there is no solution, but if your result is based on weighted voting then you look at
whether this particular person has age or loan amount which is closer to the default
ones or the non-default ones. And depending on that the classifier will predict whether
this person is going to default or not. Now, again like as we said that if K is too small
then it will be like very noisy and it will be prone to a sensitive to noise points.
On the other hand if K is very large then you the neighborhood may actually cover almost
all the data points. So, in that case it will not be like very useful. So, how to choose
the value of K? Now, not only this particular scenario in a lot of other scenarios, often
time we have to pick some value of some parameters which we also call as hyper parameters. For
example, K is an hyper parameter in case of K nearest neighbor or for example, the kind
of distance function we are using the choice of the distance to use this is also another
choice which we will have to make. Now, in general whenever we have to choose hyper parameter
values, we choose the one which likely to give the best performance on the test data.
Now, in reality you do not know the test data, you are just given the training data. So,
you are just using the training data to train your model and test data will come only in
the real world like when you are having to deploy your model to work in the real world.
So, there is no way while you are developing the model you know the test. So, there is
a process by which we do this and this is called cross validation. So, let us just assume
that we are talking about binary classification just between like class 1 and class 2. In
this case let us say it is green or red. So, your test data is something like this like
where you have both values of class 1, both values of class 2. So, this is your training
data. Now, in test data these labels are something which you do not know like whether
a test data is actually green or actually red and there is no picking. So, that means
that you when you are building the model you cannot really look at the test data and then
decide oh this is working fine for the test data and we should try that.
So, to avoid that we actually do one thing, we take the training data, we divide the training
data into two parts. In one we actually take that as an actual training set, the other
data part we keep it separate we call them as validation set. So, this validation set
is very important because this actually helps us, this helps us determine what is the ideal
parameter value for a particular hyper parameter. So, what we do is we randomly split the original
data into actual training data set and validation set. We by using the actual training set we
train several times each time with a different value of the hyper parameter and then we pick
the hyper parameter value that gives the best accuracy on the validation set.
So, validation set in some sense kind of acts as a proxy of the test set where we do not
look at the final test set, but we look at the validation set to validate our choice
of hyper parameter. So, just to summarize, so to summarize essentially KNN classifiers
are also called lazy learners because they do not build a model upfront, but rather on
the test time they try to pick up or try to look at which are the data points which are
closer to the current test data point and based on that closer neighborhood selection
we tend to apply a particular level which is majority over the neighborhood set.
Now this is different from learners which we call as eager learners such as decision
tree or rule based system where the rules are built explicitly. So, in if you compare
a model which has already been trained and then based on that you are making a decision
versus a system like KN nearest neighbor where a test time a lot of compute needs to happen.
Oftentimes KNN is much more expensive to classify unknown records. So, with this let us take
a small break and then let us come back here with let us continue our discussion on supervised
learning, but we will take up a new classifier model which is called support vector machine
or SVM. So, see you soon.